a lot of the stuff I write about
involves just having to explain using
routine statistics there's a lot of
things people believe are simply not
true right so sugar consumption has
fallen since the 1970s that is a fact
that seems to surprise nearly everybody
but it is a fact beyond question BBC's
more or less show did a episode about
this recently there the fact-checking
program on the BBC much needed and they
they confirmed that yes sugar
consumption has gone down calorie
consumption has also gone down since
1970s so given that there was relatively
little obesity in the 1970s we have got
a very reliable statistics funnily
enough but it seems to be assumed it was
probably no more than about five to
seven in 110 percent it's currently
about 26% if the sugar consumption has
gone down and calorie consumption has
gone down over that period it's not
obvious that the cause of this is people
gorging themselves with food let alone
gorge themselves with sugar or sugary
drinks
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kiss and
this is a show for you if you're bored
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts are fantastic
expert guests this week is the head of
lifestyle economics at the Institute of
Economic Affairs Chris Nolan welcome to
trigonometry it's great to be here it's
good to have you tell us a little bit
about first of all as always who you are
what's your background how are you in
the chair that you're sitting now well
as you Simon industry of Economic
Affairs know you've had a couple my
colleagues on before Kate and Steve
talking about very different issues I do
what we call lifestyle economics which
is paternalism and nanny-state kind of
stuff there's obviously a lot of
regulation a lot of political activity
around gambling and drinking smoking and
vaping and these kind of lifestyle
pleasures I would call them which may or
may not pose risk to some people and
because they pose risks they're not
regulated like your average products
necessarily and one of the things I kind
of discuss and write about is what is
actually the appropriate level of
regulation it's certainly not in my view
prohibition which is where we seem to be
moving with some of these things so I
started out writing about this stuff
about nearly 15 years ago and the
initial impetus for that was the whole
anti-smoking thing which was really
picking up around that time a few years
later you had the smoking ban in Britain
and at that time I was quite a Keeton
smoker and so the idea of smoking being
banned in pubs was not particularly
appealing to me but what I was really
interested in is where do these people
come from because I never actually met
anyone knowingly who wanted to ban
smoking in every pub in the country and
so I started delving into that and you
know what is the anti-smoking movement
and what's the history of the
anti-smoking movement so I ended up
writing what was basically a history of
the anti-smoking movement which came out
nearly 10 years ago now and in that book
I had two basic hypothesis really one
was that the anti-smoking campaign now
was going to get more and more nasty and
was going to ultimately
to Prohibition and the other was that
the anti-smoking campaign is going to be
used as a template for similar near
prohibitionist campaigns against alcohol
food gambling and everything has
happened in the last decade has pretty
much confirmed me in in in that view and
so I'm always busy because there's
always stuff in the news about it you
know barely a day goes by when there
isn't either a study saying XY z-- that
is much worse than we thought it would
be more more laws against there or some
single issue pressure group is saying
the government must act to do whatever
against whatever but it generally
involves higher taxes more restrictions
making things less affordable less
available less advertised and is
generally less appealing but all of this
really goes against what is the
mainstream I you know assumption in in
economics which is that if there isn't a
market failure which it usually isn't
then you're just better off leaving the
market alone and let people decide what
they want to do you assume people are
reasonably rational reasonably
well-informed and so if people want to
exceed the chief medical officers
guidelines for drinking you should let
them do it and the kind of political
campaigning that I write about is always
trying to push people in the opposite
direction it's always trying to make
things more inconvenient and more
expensive and those kind of policies do
have costs that aren't discussed enough
you you you are making people's lives
worse if you are deliberately
pushing them away and making it more
difficult for them to pursue their goals
basically see I'm someone who is
naturally probably very libertarian
leaning on the one hand on our hand as
I'm listening to you I'm finding very
difficult to agree with a lot of what
you're saying and hear because the
Samsun I studied economics at University
and the assumption economics always
seems to be that human beings are
reasonable rational etc but isn't the
point with all of these things like junk
food that we'll talk about like
cigarettes like drugs etc that they make
people act in ways that are either
irrational in the moment or they're
irrational from a long-term perspective
that people underestimate the impact of
having a bacon butty or a cigarette or
you know a joint or whatever on their
long-term health and the you know the
repercussions of that people don't take
that fully into account well to some
extent that's partly true and that would
be true of almost any purchase you
choose to make right but there's a
buyer's regret is quite a common thing
and it's very very common for people to
not get as much pleasure out of buying
and consuming a product than they
initially expected the problem that's
almost almost the norm but I think
actually you can assume a good degree of
both information and rationality
obviously not perfectly and there's a
whole field of behavioral economics
which tries to delve into that in more
depth and look at the psychology of
people's behavior but I think you are on
very dodgy ground when you start to
implicitly assume that the answer is for
a benign and benevolent government to
work out what we lot actually want and
push him in that direction now I would
say if there are billions of people
going to McDonald's drinking sugary
drinks on a regular basis I would assume
that's because that's actually what they
want to do and I think it's you have to
set a pretty high bar to anybody who's
going to tell you actually none of these
people want to be doing that they're not
taken in the future costs at all they
really don't enjoy these things they're
just lured him by the advertising or
they're in some way addicted to sugar or
whatever it may be
now addiction does pose a question with
regards to rationality no doubt about
that but they're ultimately the goal is
to make people free you want to have
people who are making the freest and
most best informed and rational
decisions as as possible and you are
obviously not making people more free in
my view at least if you prevent them
from doing something that's that's a
real intangible restriction on freedom
if you stop people doing something even
if you just make something less
convenience or more expensive it's a
tangible restriction on their freedom
and I think that can only be justified
if there is overwhelming evidence that
people are acting completely against
their own interests which could be the
case possibly for somebody who's
addicted to crystal meth or something
you know I think in very extreme cases
you could you could what about smoking I
mean the you know we took you will die
really want to talk about the smoking
ban a little bit but smoking as someone
who used to smoke and every now and
again I'll have a few cigarettes like it
it is unquestionably to the case that if
you smoke you massively increase your
risk of cancer heart disease etc do you
increase your chance of getting
Alzheimer's
if you die early no there's been a study
proved between the link between nicotine
and yeah there are I mean the pharmacy
Glu spent years looking at nicotine and
developing kind of drug for Alzheimer's
and things like not doesn't make it work
you're gonna live to 50 anyone how about
so there is an unquestionable link there
for what I would argue someone who to be
honest we quite enjoys a cigarette every
now and again for a very minor gain in
in pleasure or whatever you know what I
mean but but set that aside it is a
thing that gives you you could say gives
you cancer right right so what's the
benefit of having cigarettes be
available to the public and you know be
displayed everyone advertisers they
would have been xx because people do
enjoy them you know and I used to smoke
smoked for 20 years and thoroughly
enjoyed every single cigarette I smoked
I only stopped because I switched to
vaping which gives me approximately the
same amount of pleasure with with lower
risks and that's great that's come along
but how do you know about baby I'm
convinced that still smoke I mean I
basically yeah I knew the risks I looked
into this again great dad I just decided
it was worth the risk and you can say
it's only a small pleasure each
individual cigarette perhaps only is a
small pleasure but of course one
individual cigarettes not going to kill
you it's it's lots of pleasures over a
period of many decades that genuinely
does enhance people's lives and the fact
that there are you know it's addictive
or certainly to a lot of people living
was to me it except I know a lot of
people who seem to be able to take it or
leave it
doesn't change that you know people
always you know people don't get
addicted to things that are not
pleasurable right it's so don't get
addicted to doing the washing-up
particularly they they get things that
are enjoyable and the its addiction is
kind of I know you had Peter Hitchens on
recently making a similar case actually
but addiction is really very net
as a as a concept it's really very
difficult to to define it apart from
anything else nevertheless I'm not going
to split hairs but I fully accept that
if you're a smoker it is much more
difficult to abstain from the next
cigarette than it is from you know
somebody to abstain from the next cream
cake or something you know probably the
aunty sugar people would disagree even
with that so it's not a game changer to
me the fact that people don't take
future costs as seriously as they do
current benefits that that's that's not
even necessarily hyperbolic discounting
that's just discounting use makes sense
actually it's a discount in the future
to some extent and the fact that there's
an addictive element to it which is
pretty difficult to define that doesn't
change you either because at the end of
the day the the choice is between having
some bureaucrat CIL's or a government or
some politicians or some pressure groups
deciding what's best for you or you
deciding what's best for you it's a
pretty binary choice at the end of the
day and I think and this builds on on
plenty of economists people like Kim
Hayek and John Stuart Mill himself made
this argument very strongly is it's not
that we assume that individuals are
perfectly informed and perfectly
rational it's just that we know the
government isn't and even if it had much
more information than URI as individuals
there's no way it could have as much
information as the entire population and
even if it did it wouldn't it couldn't
possibly set a policy which works for
all these different people because
people have radically different
preferences they have radically
different desires people do make
different trade-offs in their lives and
some people are more risk-averse some
people are more pleasure centered so
even if we accept the individuals make
mistakes consider even if we accept
they're not perfectly informed of course
they're not you still need to make the
case that the government is going to do
this job better and I say not only
doesn't it it couldn't it can't there is
no way in which you can possibly know
all the preferences and desires of
millions of people and set a
one-size-fits-all policy that would work
for them
and what did you stand on advertising
because let's take tobacco advertising
you know that was banned on Formula one
famously and now
we've getting rid of the packets there's
only plain packets where do you stand on
it do you agree with it do you think
people identify with a particular brand
or and what people do identify bleep I'm
pretty but people are fairly brand loyal
with everything written including with
cigarettes and that's why there is
habitat you know why you need to have
lots of advertising in all these markets
because actually really quite difficult
to get people to switch from Heineken to
Carlsberg or whatever it is but that is
actually what advertising is about and
anybody in business and people in
advertising really know this and the
single issue campaign is never accept it
you know if the booze companies are
saying that we are advertising our beer
not because we're encouraging people to
drink more but because we want people
who drink beer to switch from this brand
to the other one and actually even if
only a relatively small number of people
do that it's worth millions of pounds to
them so it makes total sense for us to
spend a lot of money on advertising the
the temperance movement have never
accepted that they've always said no
it's about Creek it's about inducing
aggregate demand that's all why else
would they do it that salon they always
use if it wasn't getting kids to start
drinking if it wasn't increasing the
overall sale of alcohol why would they
do it well if you apply the argument to
lots of other products take the
toothpaste or something like that right
take cat food why do they advertise
cafard is not to get cats to eat more
food it's not you know advertise toilet
paper or toothpaste to get people to use
these products more frequently we there
advertise because there are universally
bought they're very very popular and if
you can shift to one or two percent of
the market in your favor it's worth a
lot of money for you so I think we can
accept that with everyday goods like
toilet paper for some reason we don't
always accept it with things like like
alcohol so I I'm a big defender of
advertising actually I don't know not
many people are there's two good reasons
to defend it one is more than two
actually better what one is quite
straightforward it provides a lot of
free stuff for us and people seem to
forget about that you know yeah you free
copy of the Metro with a standard that's
there because of advertising using
Facebook and Twitter for free that's
there because of advertising using most
things on the Internet there your
commercial television stations are there
because of advertising so they are
annoying adverts and I'm not a fan of
watching Ivers particularly and yeah
TV advertising is going down the drain
because everyone can skip through them
there and it's a big problem but I do
appreciate the benefits that it brings
me just as a consumer of newspapers and
and TV programs you know and those
programs will get worse and the number
of stations will decline if the
government starts clamping down on other
forms of advertising having already
dealt with tobacco like so-called junk
food which is the next step and gambling
advertising was probably going to go as
well I think all of that takes money and
I've got an interest in this as a I'm a
big fan of snooker and that tobacco
advertising ban had a massive effect on
the game of snooker it nearly destroyed
it you know there was one time after
that ban came in there were about four
tournaments in the entire world there
was no money in the game no one was
coming through the smoking ban then and
hit the grass roots actually incidents
nuclear clubs are just tearing terrible
trouble probably never really recover
because I would say there was no good no
no so we really clobbered snooker that
was a bad thing for snooker fans
babbling personal complains and it to be
fair to bury her and you've got the game
back on its feet now there's loads of
torment but that's happened largely
because us if you watch any snooker
they're all sponsored by online gambling
companies and it might not be long
before online gambling companies are
prevented from sponsorship and
advertising of anything so there's not a
bottomless pit of advertisers who can
replace these guys you think that's the
thing so um yeah from a consumers point
of view just of the media and of various
free things advertising is good and it's
also a good thing in terms of just
letting people know what's out there and
of course we all know that you know we
all know coke exists so from that point
of view doesn't need to remind us that
coke exists but it is any battle with
Pepsi and other drinks and if they
stopped advertising its kind of games
there if they stopped advertising Pepsi
will win it's in both their interests
really to stop advertising yeah and then
the market wouldn't really change very
much and as long as all the other soft
drinks stopped advertising - they've
actually make more money and that
actually is what happened with the
tobacco companies after the advertising
but they were spending a fortune but it
was a it were all defensive advertising
a lot people who attack out appetizing
don't understand
much of it is actually defensive the
people who talk about corporate power
and the manipulative power of
advertising it's it's it's a paper tiger
these guys are terrified that somebody
else is gonna eat their lunch and so you
know in a funny kind of way it actually
helped the tobacco companies make more
money because they saved a vast amount
it didn't really have any effect on the
smoking rate and it didn't really have
any no he didn't make much difference to
market share so they just battled it out
on price
I suppose a counter argument with that
bit would would be product placement
which we see a lot in films and you see
James Bond yeah
and you see it with bond you see it with
James Dean Marlon Brando they take the
cigarette they tap it they put it in
they light it it looks [ __ ] cool
doesn't it yeah I think it does yeah of
yeah I don't think a lot of that was
product placement but I mean there has
been product placement yes tobacco and
alcohol obviously bond things you got
Heineken and laptop computers and they
pay fortunately for that but that
probably works much better than
advertising actually having an
associated with James Bond literally
there in the film must be yeah well
worth the money but now I mean India all
days baton yeah most people smoked and
therefore most characters on in film
smokes and the fact that I can indeed
works well from a filmmaking point of
view doesn't it the fact that you've got
this pause where you can zoom in and
you've got that moment where the light
the cigarette and as you say it looks
quite cool so I don't think a lot of
that was kind of paid for promotion as
it were by my tobacco companies to my
knowledge there's a kind of chicken and
egg thing as well because if smoking is
cool and you have a cool character then
you want to portray them as cool you
give them a cigarette as well I mean
have you noticed a lot of the kind of
Netflix documentaries and all the films
now they seem deliberately said in the
past just so people can smoke yeah
stranger things we've seen stranger
things so to say in the 80s doesn't need
to be said yeah really I mean they get a
bit of mileage out the fellows like some
of those old 80s girls but it just means
that everyone could be smoking all the
time indoors
it looks quite cool Mad Men is a perfect
example of that right the one instance
what I would disagree view is I'm a big
football fan I love football and when I
watch a football match now it just seems
to be bombarded with gambling and nerds
and that isn't really a problem for me
I'm a 36 year old man fair enough you
know there you want to put you do what
you do but I worry about and again I
hate the way I'm gonna say this I worry
about the effect on young people
especially children who watch
football then suddenly become bombarded
with adverts big men being made aware of
gambling and an age when they don't
necessarily need to be I I don't know I
think the evidence on that is it's not
very strong actually that the gambling
advertising has any effect on people's
uptake a gambling or of gamblers
becoming problem gamblers if you look at
other than it has no impact on the
number of people doing gambling why are
they doing it then and now you're asking
the question because I didn't take take
your take your online gambling company
here right Winston's and so stuff like
that right there is a huge amount of
that at the moment because you get a lot
of advertising in the market when a
market has recently opened up and people
are fighting from a market share and you
get a lot of advertising in the market
where the companies think the door is
about to close on advertising and at the
moment you've got both those things
happening in the online world it's a
relatively fresh market so there's still
a lot of companies they were battling to
be the market leader but also the fear
that any minute the government is
probably going to ban this TV
advertising it's only been legal so
they're fighting for market share
they're not trying to get more people to
gamble absolutely yeah they're fighting
for market share yeah I don't think this
there's there's any real tell about I
mean obviously it did they would be
quite happy if it made people to start
gambling and I dare say it does get
people to put a bet on a football that
they wouldn't they wouldn't have done
otherwise I mean I put a bet on the
football just a few days ago for their
very reason I was not because the
advertising actually but because I had a
phone in my hand and it was convenient
and it was a game I wasn't that
interested in but putting a tenner on
one of the sides was gonna make it more
interesting for me which is actually
what a lot of recreational gambling's
about just about giving you a bit more
pleasure from watching an otherwise
meaningless game and I lost I backed I
Batman tonight and they lost for the
first time in months but I wouldn't have
done that had I had to leave the house
and go to a bookies right now that
wasn't advertising that was just having
an online convenient way of doing it so
yeah the fact that people can gamble on
their phones and on their computers as
no doubt made more people put more bets
on but there's no evidence at all that
the liberalisation of gambling that
we've seen last 15 years has led to any
increase in pro memory whatsoever
despite the fact that every now and
again the newspapers will claim
otherwise it just hasn't we've been
measuring it for 20 years and he's it's
okay it's low it's a lot lower than it
is in places like Hong Kong or Sweden
where they have a more
active set of laws on gambling and it
hasn't gone up hasn't gone down but it
hasn't gone up use about 0.6 percent of
gamblers I'm pretty small Hong Kong's
like 2 percent China is like 4 percent
Las Vegas you won't be surprised to hear
it's about 5 what exactly they're going
but the question I've always been very
very interested in this what
responsibility do gambling companies
have for addiction and should they
contribute and help people who have
become addicted as a result of the
voices that they promote and have in
society it's a good question I don't
know how much responsibility they have I
mean does a car company have
responsibility for motor accidents does
an alcohol committee have responsibility
for the people you know getting drunk
and falling over I I don't think so
really I think it makes sense for them I
think possibly moral aids you know if
you're making a lot of money
morally there's a case for taking a
slice of that and setting a problem
gambling charity stuff and they do do
that and you can always say what it
should be giving more well ok but how
much right they do give millions about
these companies and a daresay someone
could afford to give more and it would
look good for them it'd be good
corporate responsibility but I'm not
sure whether morally they have a
responsibility necessarily to do that
unless they feel they're acting
unethically in the first place which
presumably they don't well let's let's
move our way through the drugs pyramid
and we've with a step up because as you
said we had Peter Hitchens on the show
quite recently and that's kind of how
this interviews happened you and I were
talking about it and you were like I've
argued with Peter about this many times
so let me just try and recall some of
the kind of things that he said he said
that first of all his central argument I
think is that people who consume drugs
should be treated as criminals because
it's a voluntary action and that once a
drug is legalized you can't you can't go
back you can't prohibit it again and
also particularly on cannabis his point
was that there seems to be he didn't
necessarily say was causation but they
certainly correlation between the use of
marijuana and violent acts mass
shootings
terrorism etc he reeled off a very
impressive list of mass shootings and
terrorist attacks that have been
committed by people who were habitual
users of can
so if he were here if he was sitting in
Francis seat let's say what would you
say to him well firstly on the point
about yeah once something have been
legalized you can't prohibit it he talks
as if these drugs have always been
illegal if you take a longer view the
war on drugs is only 100 years old and
there wasn't actually much of a problem
with recreational drug use while they
were openly available openly available
to anybody he'd get him you know in the
19th century most people would have
taken opium in some form often just for
pain relief or something but it was
pretty widely used but the world there
wasn't any real moral panic about about
opium use huge moral panic about gin and
alcohol beer but never about opium and
cannabis to be fair was never very
widely used but it was it was an America
so some these things were legal and we
did prohibit them and it hasn't worked
now Peters argument is is really quite
unique actually if you have arguments
about drug reform legalization the
traditional battle is between someone
like me who thinks at a it's basically
morally wrong to be stopping people from
consuming these these drugs but also
that actually they're the consequential
argument is probably more compelling for
most people which is people more people
are dying as a result of drugs being
illegal you know far more deaths from
opiates mainly heroin then the word 100
years ago when you know people who use
them freely and there's all sorts of
reasons for that about how the supply
chain makes these drugs more
concentrated more lethal more addictive
and my vision is to go back to kind of
pre-prohibition stage now the the
argument against that is traditionally
like what its history is actually
immoral for people to be using these
drugs and we should use every argument
against the men Peter does say that but
he goes one step further and he just
says there isn't a war on drugs and it's
quite difficult to then blame the war on
drugs for anything yeah so I would be
saying well you know
heroin for example wasn't wasn't used
into the war drugs came along it's only
come along to replace the smoking of
opium which is relatively harmless
because it suits the drug dealers to
have something there's much more compact
much more exported
but that doesn't cut any ice for Peter
because he just said well the drugs are
basically illegal no always studied
before I mean that's the gist of his
book the war we never fought is that
essentially the drugs might as well be
legal that the police don't really
enforce cannabis but that's really it
but there's a big difference between
that and then being legal right so a lot
of the problems I have with the war on
drugs is that people cannot walk into a
shop and buy something and know what's
in it no you know what is likely to do
there's no regulation whatsoever the
supply chain behind that is built on
blood that would be illegal market right
if we somebody could do that obviously
you cannot do that and so you've got you
know ecstasy pills which were
adulterated and kill people that clearly
wouldn't happen if you had legal XE but
Peter this overlooks and says oh well
the fact that you get a slap on the
wrist for possession of cannabis means
that the whole thing doesn't really
exist and therefore any argument you
make about the harms of prohibition is
invalid because there isn't prohibition
Michael series mu the mere fact that you
can you can be done for possession
actually people do get done for
possession particularly a Class A drugs
yeah they can have their careers ruined
actually quite quite often and sometimes
not very often it's serve time in prison
just for possession you know possession
was never illegal in America under
alcohol prohibition right so the
prohibition of drugs is actually much
more far-reaching than the prohibition
of alcohol was and it's suffering from
the same in inevitable problems
how would a society how would you
envision a society where drugs are legal
would it be the sort of the Amsterdam
model where you going to a coffee shop
and you're picking at your weed and you
sit down and you smoke would it be
completely legal how would you go about
because licensing it and regulating it
well broadly speaking it would be like
and you you would have I think probably
specialist shops is probably the way to
go so like you're all head shops before
the government banned legalize or used
tobacco so a specialist shop licensed
but not restricted in number you know
some of the places in America that have
done this haven't done it very well
because they've turned it into a cozy
state-mandated cartel right and said you
get shortages and not enough competition
and they've banned branding in some in
some places and stuff I wouldn't do
anything I would have branding I would
have probably some level of advertising
I think politically you need to be
realistic that you're not going to have
a great deal of it but I think it is
important that that we have brands
because people know where they are
they're you know it's a real incentive
this is one of the things overlooked
when it comes to advertising of brands
there's a huge incentive for a company
to maintain quality and to maintain
their own reputation if they have a
brand that is worth a fortune if you
haven't got that if you just got
cannabis shops where you've got
anonymous pots of green leaves and
nobody really knows what it is there is
no incentive whatsoever to maintain the
quality because no one knows where
they're getting it from so actually I
think you need to do neat app brands I
would have specialist shops for things
like cannabis I would essentially
legalize all the drugs themselves but
not necessarily every derivative that's
the thing so I don't think I would
legalize crack cocaine heroin for
example but I would certainly legalize
opium smoking and I would have opium
smoking bars obviously there would be no
smoking ban under my so yes opium
smoking now I'm not going to stop people
from you know making crack a game in
their kitchens
you know I'm certain no gonna stop
people from growing their own cannabis
and stuff now I just hope that if you
give people a much safer variety of the
drug essentially the variety of the drug
that was consumed circa 1880 mmm all
right so that would be smoking opium
rather than intravenous injection of
heroin
there would be some form of cocaine I
mean cocaine is a difficult one I think
most legalizes except the cocaine is a
difficult one because I mean it does
play to your right irrationality point
right when when people are on the stuff
it's clearly very very moreish for a lot
of people and they don't necessarily act
in the most responsible rational way
however I as comedians who have formed
to audiences of some of whom have been
on that yeah I think yes it's so
difficult but it is out there already
already token in London it's it's just
it seems everybody's on it yeah despite
the fact it's really expensive yeah so I
don't know cacain was never used all
that much actually before prohibition it
was kind of associated with a few
Bohemians and actors yeah but it was
used it was mainly used actually in kind
of patent medicines and stuff and maybe
that might be the way forward we we look
at the drugs are being consumed today ie
under prohibition and just assume that a
legalized market would be just exactly
the same drugs but sold legally I don't
think it would be like that because as I
said before prohibition has incentivized
suppliers to produce these drugs in the
most powerful and concentrated forms
which is not actually responding to
demand skunk is a great example of this
right so skunk is a fundamentally
different joke really to what marijuana
is like up until the late 1990s and it
has caused a lot of problems that Peter
talks about is this a Peter doesn't get
that the solution isn't to try and have
some kind of Iranian style enforcement
of drinkers the solution is to go back
to that kind of stuff because I actually
know a lot of people who start smoking
cannabis around that time because it was
suddenly getting much stronger and
people didn't know why people didn't
know about the THC level of the CBD
level they just knew that it wasn't that
Pleasant and they were getting paranoid
so a lot of people stopped consuming at
that point but a lot of people just
started really upping their consumption
and this is where you see now and most
people know someone who's kind of
turning to reclusive yeah lose it really
as a result of skunk but that wasn't
that wasn't the suppliers following
demand for really strong high THC low
CBD cannabis that was just then going
well we can we can breed these strains
and we can charge twice as much for it
same physical volume therefore great
right the same reason under prohibition
in America people weren't Al Capone
wasn't something bit raucous it was too
bulky he was selling spirits the
stronger the better but more bang for
your buck more profit
same thing with skunk so I think if you
legalize skunk I think what yes sorry if
you legalize cannabis I think what you
would have to do would have we'd have to
have some sort of level some people
limit on the THC and also more
importantly I think a minimum limit of
CBD CBD is the antipsychotic bit that
kind of balances out the THC nature is
wonderful and putting these things into
plants isn't it and over time the
crossbreeding has led to less much less
of that almost non-existent amounts of
that and that's really caused the the
psychological that's really interesting
yeah one thing I was going to ask is we
all we I think most people are aware of
the cost of addiction and drug use for
individual people and for society you
know drug addicts people becoming
homeless people living on the street you
know violence sometimes as Peter talks
about all this kind of stuff but I think
we so often forget that the drug war
which I personally think is absolutely
being waged has a huge cost as well and
that cost is tremendous in terms of
people dying in in places where these
drugs are being produced where they're
being trafficked from I mean Mexico is
essentially a non state because it's
it's run by cartels and thousands of
people are dying tens of thousands die
every year it's it and in the most
brutal and horrific ways I mean the
stuff that's coming out of Mexico is
just shocking yeah and before that was
Colombia you know where are the weather
the weather the capital of the global
drug industry is is always the murder
capital of the world yeah yeah so that's
one but also in Western societies the
number of people who end up in prison
simply for using or being involved in in
in drugs who otherwise would not have
been in prison who otherwise would not
have encountered killers and murderers
and rapists and whatever and would not
have then become violent and you know
would not have been radicalized in that
way that's a huge cost as well isn't it
yeah the greatest cost really is in the
the countries that are producing it the
utter corruption that just infests every
element of countries which is usually
fairly corrupt to begin with
just get worse yeah that's the greatest
caskets like say tens of thousands of
people are dying every year it totally
undermines normal institutions just
kills a country from within really but
yeah there's other costs I mean to you
Peter is right when he says there's very
few drug users actually in person well
very few people being sent to prison
merely for possession it's mainly drug
dealers but of course I consider
drugging to be a victimless crime
anyway really already should be under
under a legal system so yeah that could
the costs are very extensive it costs
the government Department has a huge
amount of money in terms of prosecuting
it and possibly controlling the borders
whereas we could be making a lot of
money out of it you know I wrote a study
last year for the ia looking what how
much revenue the government could
realistically expect if it legalized
cannabis and I gave various different
options of how it would go about it what
kind of tax rate you would you would
have on it I think it would be
reasonable by the way to have an extra
kind of syntax on cannabis just to make
it politically plausible really probably
meant apart from anything and we're
looking at you know just the tax on the
product would bring in about a billion
pounds a year I think somewhere close to
that you then add on the extra income
tax and business rates and so on that
all the the businesses around it the
retailers and manufacturers are paying
and then the indirect employment and
taxes generated by that that's it you
know it's not a game-changing amount of
money for government the spends that
kind of cash should it does but it
certainly better than spending money
which is what we're doing at the moment
so I I'm pretty positive about this you
know I'm I everything else I write about
apart from vaping it's just a losing
battle you know release is steadily
getting worse from my perspective but
really oh yeah I mean everything's
getting more and more you know
regulating the clamp down on I mean more
or less run out of things to do to
smoker's the food thing is just taken
off sugar in particular over the last
few years and that's it's not going to
end we've got public of England you know
doing this food reformulation scheme
which is just insane hardly anybody
really knows about it but it's going on
and as I say vaping in this country at
least has been good because we've
actually had the public health agencies
on site but
most of the country's it's horrible
America is unbelievable what they do
with vaping
so when cannabis is is the one positive
aspect really globally because things
are moving in the right direction you've
had kind of legalized you've had about
ten US states legalize and more to come
Uruguay is legalize so I don't think
Britain will be the next off the blocks
because we rarely are but I think once a
few European countries start legalizing
Britain will realize that it doesn't
actually lead to more problems actually
alleviates quite a lot of problems and
they're making a lot of money the
government's I mean that's what's done
in America America started water drugs
don't forget you start the war on drugs
I think got the UN to get the rest of
the world to abide by the war on drugs
and yet its leading away in in ending it
at least with cannabis and they've done
it because the governors of various
states see their neighboring state
making a fortune
from taxes and nobody really wants to
bring back prohibition in these states
you know overnight it's a big news story
when it happens what's going to happen
nothing happens basically the same
number of people carry on smoking
cannabis you might see a slight increase
in the number of adults consuming it a
slight decrease in number of under-21s
using it apart from that you know the
Sun still rises in the morning nothing
really changes and the government's
raking in millions of dollars and so the
other states thinking maybe we should be
doing this now where do you stand on
prostitution do you believe that we
should be legalizing prostitution or do
you think we should it should be as it
currently is at the moment illegal I
think we should legalize it for similar
reasons and I think that we should be
legalizing a lot of things that are
currently prohibited you know I'm not a
fan of prostitution but it's gone on
it's the oldest profession it's gone on
forever and the primarily women who are
involved in it are frequently murdered
and beaten up and cheated and yes it's a
it's a terrible situation really so
given that is not going to go away and
given that there are major risks
involved for the people working in the
industry yeah it should be regulated as
it is
in Amsterdam where it seems to work very
well
now to really see any argument against
lots of people saying that you're
profiting off the exploitation of women
yeah well but the people are doing that
already this is a trouble a lot of these
prohibitionists they kind of they just
ignore the reality what happens at the
moment and just compare what a legalized
market would be to utopia which never
happens this is what Peters Pete
imagines there is some way in which by
this using you know extreme state force
you can get people to stop taking drugs
I think won't happen and America has
tested this to destruction you've got
people in prison for 25 years on the
three strikes and you're out rule
because they'd be found with a spliff
you Iran Iran a few years ago executed
somebody twice for drug dealing they
hung him and then it turned out when he
was in the morgue he hadn't actually
died and he revived itself and they hung
him again you can't really enforce the
war drugs any more heavily than that
yeah and yet there is still rampant drug
use um no you are exactly the kind of
person you sound like guys we wanted to
take a moment to say thank you to every
single one of you that has supported us
on patreon subscribe star that sent us
money through PayPal we could not do the
show without you please keep supporting
us and if you haven't already please
consider doing so because that is
exactly what allows us to keep improving
the show every single week having said
that we've now also got a corporate
sponsor to sell out to indeed we have
and it is the magazine the week and what
the week does is it pulls together the
best articles from over 200 different
sources from publications such as a
Times The Telegraph all four are one
liberal snowflake fan the Guardian they
do exactly what we do on the show which
is pulled together balanced opinions
from different sides so that you can
make your own mind up and you don't get
stuck in an echo chamber and if you want
to take advantage of this special offer
all you need to do is go to the week
coat don't
UK slash offer use our special code
trigger and you'll get six free issues
of the week the great thing about the
week is that allows you to read less and
no more which is going to appeal to
people like Frances who can barely read
and it's not just news the week also
brings you the latest from the world of
sports so if you want to find out what's
going on in the transfer window who
mentor United are going to sign the week
will also deliver you the latest
freshest news on that which one appealed
to someone like Constantine because he's
a massive virgin well anyway guys
seriously we know that you've got busy
lives we understand that you're not
going to be reading 200 articles a week
and that's what the magazine does it
brings together those articles in the
one combined easy package that you can
read and know what's going on join
thousands trust the week as their
essential curated new source try for
yourself and get your first six issues
completely free to take advantage of
this great offer visit the week code UK
forward slash offer enter our code which
is of course trigger and get your first
six issues completely free
[Music]
I'm the former teacher I was a teacher
for 10 years and there is undoubtedly an
obesity problem in schools especially
teachers and children now how much
responsibility do people like McDonald's
have with the supersizing of all the
rest of it with the amount of drinks and
with matter sugar in drinks with their
salt and the chips and you know and the
fact that they are seen it's what it's
very addictive and some a lot of some
studies have said it's more addictive
than certain drugs for example yeah well
they would do and they yeah cheese more
addictive than heroin was a story a few
years ago I was fantastic some mouse
study proved that well two mice maybe
yeah yeah right they gave some of them
heroin some cheese to another mice like
cheese things like you say this thing
isn't it well before I answer your
question can I ask you a question how
many a many kids are at your school
approximately at that time it was a pro
I was working at primary school so
there's 320 and honestly how many of
them would you say were obese obese
right okay I would say around 20 percent
25 percent 25 cents yeah yeah I was
working in Lambeth which is drumroll
please the fattest borough in London
oh is that right yeah absolutely yeah
that's probably slightly less than the
official statistics say but it still has
surprised me yeah is that me because I
won't go into it now but if anybody
wants to check out my my articles on
this I've written quite a lot about how
the child and obesity measure just does
not measure beastie particularly when
then measure it nationally so I've got
big questions about the actual the size
of the problem but and there is no doubt
that there are more children than when I
was at school yeah and the question is
what if anything can you do about it I
the the junk food thing the McDonald's
and so on obviously comes up a lot I'm
not really aware of a great deal of
evidence showing the obese people or
children or adults go to McDonald's or
any other fast-food chain more than more
than your average person actually it
seems to be taken for
granted that this is linked but I'm not
sure really there's very much compelling
evidence she's suggesting that I mean my
view is it's it's mainly about physical
activity Sony isn't about sugar I mean a
lot of the stuff I write about involves
just having to explain using routine
statistics there's a lot of things
people believe are simply not true right
so sugar consumption has fallen since
the 1970s that is a fact that seems to
surprise nearly everybody but it is a
fact beyond question BBC's more-or-less
show did a episode about this recently
there's a fact-checking program on the
BBC much needed and they they confirmed
that yes sugar consumption has gone down
calorie consumption has also gone down
since 1970s so given that there was
relatively little obesity in the 1970s
we haven't got very reliable statistics
funnily enough but it seems to be
assumed it was probably no more than
about five to seven no more than 10%
it's currently about 26% if the sugar
consumption has gone down and calorie
consumption has gone down over that
period it's not obvious that the cause
of this is people gorging themselves
with food let alone gorging themselves
with sugar or sugary drinks that's not
to say some people aren't fat because of
they drink 3 liters of coke and of
course they are the people beasts for
all sorts of different reasons but
looking at it from a the population
level that there isn't really a smoking
gun there what there is a smoking gun
for I think and again it's quite hard to
get statistics on this is physical
inactivity now we've given that we
haven't been putting fit bits on people
for the last 50 years it's quite kind of
hard to work out the trends public
health England say that physical
activity has gone down by 24% since the
1960's which seems are kind of spurious
accurate figure something that doesn't
seem very well defined yeah but I think
broadly speaking that is correct and I
think common sense tells you that if you
just look at what we have not just
people's daily lives you know all the
you know you don't need to stand up to
change the TV station anymore right you
know there's so many labor-saving
devices at home but more importantly
occupationally you know there are just
millions of jobs over the course the
last 50 years have gone from being
manual to being office job
and it's interesting that you saw the
rise in obesity initially with the the
middle class it was your classic fat man
who was gonna die a heart disease was
your your Citibank or something right
that was how used to be I think over
time it's now predominantly or
disproportionately more working-class be
blue blue collar people who would have
been blue colored but of course they're
now they've got white collars on because
they're working in in tally sales are in
so I think that you've got a real
realistically you've got to look at
physical activity and there is stuff you
can do with that course in schools
because you've got a bit more control
over the people when they're children
during a school you haven't got much
control over adults there is no form of
regulation really that you can bring in
that certainly wouldn't be totalitarian
to get people's exercise more and I
think many people want to take the
Japanese approach of doing you know 20
minutes here robux before you start work
so there isn't a lot that the government
can do about it and as a result there
not being much the government can do
about it
people don't really talk about it Chris
if people want to follow you on twitter
and follow your writing where do they go
for that
CJ Snowden on Twitter I got a block
called public love I in first I'll share
with the in sheer economic affairs and a
book called killjoys which you could
download from IA UK which is my kind of
general critique of paternalism
fantastic we'll check out all of that
and as always follow us at trigger pod
on all social media subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button to make sure
you can notified when the videos come
out give us an iTunes review and I think
that's it guys we will see in a week
from now absolutely and also as well
please check because our YouTube have a
lovely little habit of unsubscribe or
you we've had modes of complaints if
that has happened to you could you
please read subscribe and tweet us
because yeah we need to know about it
thanks a lot guys and we'll see you next
week
[Music]